what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends
[Music]
yes hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine stallone
look you guys if you haven't already
noticed
we have a very special guest
joining us today we're gonna start the
show off a little bit differently
we thought this one right here is an
eager beaver we're gonna kick it off
with her right away we'll do a little
weekly update with her but we thought
let's start the show
by introducing this lovely lady
not only have you guys been asking for
her constantly since day one
and i don't blame you we wanted to make
sure this episode was perfect
before we brought her on because this
woman is
not only one of the kindest most
selfless most
incredible individuals really that's
ever walked the planet
it's real when people come up to you
that you don't know and say the same
thing yeah
she is smart she's hard-working she's a
heart of gold
and is quite literally close to perfect
i didn't think anyone could be but she
really is not only is she a wonderful
wife but she's a great mom as well
thank you thank you so here is our
number one
fan of the unwax podcast jennifer
fleeman stella
[Music]
[Applause]
and she is a cavapoo fanatic and a
businesswoman
and what else great mom best job in the
whole world is being a good mom so
thank you for coming on well you know we
sophia's right when she said that
we really wanted to make sure we were so
comfortable with podcasting before
having you just because we didn't want
to
mess it up you're such a special one
thank you thank you we were nervous
a little bit we wanted to make sure that
this was genuinely going to be great for
you because we wanted our podcast to be
set up
right and i know you not that you you
have high ex like you're not
pressuring us or anything but we just i
don't know i'm very
proud of you guys because i came in here
and i'm like wow this is
the real deal you guys have set this up
really nicely you're always prepared
and i'm proud to be on your show so
thank you for having me
i'm like you're like probably my most
intimidating guest i don't know if it's
for sistine but
really yeah i'm [ __ ] bricks right
now why
i'm so easy girls mom you're easy but
what i love about the stallones is that
we're very honest with each other yes
very true so sometimes you know i get
nervous because i don't want to hear
that i messed up
well here's the thing i know your
abilities i know how
strong you are how smart you are how
hard working
so when i see you doing average work i'm
going to tell you you can do better now
if i there we go
but if i thought that you couldn't do it
i wouldn't expect if i
if you were a c student and i knew your
c student i'd be like
excited if you had got all c's but i
knew you were an a
student yeah i didn't know and i got it
and then i knew that you guys
i could push you to be your best so
that's why what i've always done i'm
still really nervous but it's good to
hear it thank you
um i'm very impressed so thank you so
normally you guys know that we have our
weekly update which is usually
some chaotic thing or some normal thing
that's happened to steve steen and i
and you know what's kind of funny is our
weekly update actually includes
our mom and so we thought why not just
give the viewers
your point of view as well oh great let
me just set the scene for you guys this
happened maybe
four or five days ago
sophia my mom and i decided let's do a
little girl's day let's go
shopping let's have some fun we're
driving around
it's hot i mean how hot do you think it
was maybe 89 degrees
but it was like 100 humidity so it was
not just how hot it was so humid
unbreathable yeah yeah right and we're
driving home
i see a turtle this doesn't happen in
l.a
i see a turtle just walking on the
sidewalk and i knew
it is not going to make it to the
stoplight it is going to die we have to
go save this turtle so immediately i say
mom turn around let's go save a life
right without hesitation jennifer goes
let's turn around make a u-turn make it
pop a u-turn
what we're not used to in florida is how
many one-way streets there are yeah
so she pops a u-turn
you know little fast and furious vin
diesel action we're going for a good
like 30 seconds
no problem there we don't even notice
anything is happening
and then tell until you know a bunch of
cars start honking and people giving us
funny looks like
like what like we're doing something
wrong and we're like what are you doing
we're saving doing
animals what are you doing she quickly
realizes
well i quickly realized when the cars
are coming straight
towards you and they're all yelling at
me and i'm like what do you want me to
do i've got a turtle to save
we're going down i got a kid in the back
seat that is very upset
saying the turtle's going she's like the
turtle needs it so now we're going down
a one-way street and you guys are
probably thinking okay big deal
everyone's gone on a one-way street
before oh no no
no no no this would happen to me
so there's this uh guy that i always run
into at the gym
i call him hot gym guy and every time i
go to the gym i see him
[ __ ] i know he's going to listen hey
what's up
um at least i didn't say ugly gym guy
you said that's just
our hot gym guy there we go
so after we do this embarrassing u-turn
we ended up leaving the turtle and yeah
i couldn't sleep at night but that's
another story
i get a text about five minutes later
from hot gym guy
and he goes hey just saw you going down
a one-way street
you good question mark head-on
wrong way and i said let me just
embarrass myself more
i was trying to save a turtle and he's
like what
like actually what i go up to him
actually he comes up to me the next day
in the gym says so word around palm
beach is that you're just saving turtles
yeah i'm like wow i look super cool
and uh seeing him this weekend
situation here there's my daughter for
you there we go
started rough i did good you know what i
don't know what happened to the turtle
oh that's true that's so sad but it is a
it is a florida turtle they do
end up finding water they'll go into a
pool or a little how do you know
because that's what turtles do system
questions
how did turtles end up there how did the
turtle end up there
it had to come from had to come from
somewhere somewhere it didn't just
appear out of thin air
like bury itself in the ground it'll be
my mission this week to find it
yes we will find that one turtle that
you almost caused a car accident
so let's stop talking about turtles and
start talking about
mom we obviously know everything about
you already
but since you are a guest i thought we
could sort of
not only have an open discussion but do
sort of an interview based type thing
just so the listeners know
who you are you know i definitely want
to start with your childhood and your
upbringing because i think
that's a really interesting story that
you haven't really spoken about before
are you comfortable with that yes okay
very comfortable
let me know at any time i'm just kidding
i'll pull the plug so let's just start
with where you were raised
your family your uh how many seconds so
i was raised in the san fernando valley
that's um a very large area yeah um
like totally for sure like totally for
sure like we went to the gallery like oh
my god
for sure it's so erotica like totally
awesome
so i grew up with fast times at richmond
high if you can imagine that's where i
grew up like i grew up with that whole
area of
valley girl right that was in my
backyard you you raised us daddy just to
show us film so
the films you showed us we looked way
better it was like say elmo's fire
it was fast times it was valley girl
yeah it was all those those are the
great great you know 80s films yeah well
anyways i grew up in the valley
i'm one of seven kids um i'm number six
of seven so i have four older brothers
and they were born in minnesota because
my mom's from north dakota
my dad's from minnesota they had four
boys in minnesota
and then decided to go out west end up
in california
and they had an a whole other batch of
children
they had three girls so they had my
older sister tricia
me and then my younger sister julie
that's a lot that's a lot
it's a big big family so it was it was
it was
it was okay you know we didn't have a
lot of money um my mom was a
stay-at-home mom
and and my dad worked and but we made it
work we worked
everyone had a job we didn't have you
know we mowed the lawn cleaned the house
made our own lunches
but then tragedy struck my dad had a
heart attack and it was
died uh instantly on a golf course
and he was only 47. how old were you i
was 11.
so that is when my whole life went from
you know just and kind of like everybody
else
had was just growing up you know had to
work hard but then everything changed
because my mom had never had a a job
besides being a housewife which is a big
job but
she uh had to get a job and uh she
didn't know anything about money and
and and and she didn't know anything
about how to pay a bill because my dad
paid all the bills wrote all the checks
so she had to learn all that
in the meantime she developed a really
terrible drinking problem so she became
a
full-on alcoholic yeah and drank a lot
and
that left seven kids on their own well
my brothers are a little older so they
were out of the house and they were sort
of
figuring themselves out and my sisters
and i
sort of raised each other and right so
you have a nine-year-old
an 11 year old and a 14 year old raising
an extraordinary amount today they would
probably take you out of the home right
because that is not that responsibility
i couldn't even imagine
putting out someone that age so you you
guys you i remember you telling me
stories of how you guys were sort of
just feral children like every man for
themselves
we were feral children you are hungry
you needed to figure out money for lunch
so i had every babysitting job in the
neighborhood um
i learned to drive a car at 14 i was
doing grocery shopping and we
and then my mom would come home and
leave us money
in an envelope every week or week and a
half she'd just come home and appear but
then leave again
and we would my sisters and i would take
that cash and we'd go to the local
grocery store
and we had three sections of the grocery
cart things we needed like
toilet paper and a bag of apples and
a few things and then things that we
would like to have
and then wish lists so the grocery when
we would be shopping we had this
not a lot of money yeah we made sure we
got our essentials first and then we
said okay
to the cashier how what are we at and
then she'd tell us
the you know final price and then we'd
add the extra stuff in when we could but
it it taught me a lot about money it
taught me a lot about
saving it taught me a lot about
responsibility and responsibility
not not that any 11 year old should have
that type of responsibility
at such a young age because you don't
really have any adult
telling you what's right and wrong or
you know you hit a lot of different
milestones at that age and
and you're sort of kind of like thrown
into this thrown into this world and i
would
copy other families that i would go and
have dinner at their home so i'd see how
like a husband and wife behaved and how
they raised their
children you've always just been very
observant and i definitely want to get
into
how you being a little street smart
little
little savvy kid a little grungy rat
but because i feel like a lot of the
things you do now
i can still see as a self-reflection on
things you do when you're younger
i mean the way you organize everything
the way you're on top of i mean our
household is
perfect yeah it is because i mean i
didn't have anyone cleaning my house
growing up so like
everything had to be perfect or it would
be end up being a disaster so
i didn't one thing when you grow up
without parents
you can't you kind of realize that you
can't make mistakes like kids that have
a great home and
two parents they they're allowed to kind
of like fall down like i didn't have
a backup plan i didn't have anyone to
pick me up if i fell so it was like
until you fell you fell hard and you
had to get up off the street or to warn
you about anything or teach you like
okay you shouldn't go down this street
or you shouldn't be walking back and
forth to school alone and when you did
the stupidest
things as kids i mean we would play
chicken in the street and like literally
lay down in the street and hope
a car wouldn't hit us or jay the hardest
part i didn't even tell you that story
i mean we would do the dumbest things
and like i mean why don't
you why we just didn't well i mean i'm
i'm not surprised though you didn't have
anyone telling you
not to do so and right i mean i guess it
did teach you a lot of things about
growing up but it also just
really kind of threw you into this whole
lifestyle
an adult world where you know it's like
you didn't i didn't
really have a childhood yeah because i
was so concerned about making sure i had
enough money
yeah that you had a place to sleep in a
food to eat
exactly that's tough but i want to talk
about you in high school
because i think contrary to how
beautiful of a woman she is and she was
in high school as well
you were bullied and picked on the
stories that you tell me
i just want to find these people that
were mean to you and just
ring their necks really but i want to
talk about you were voted what were you
voted most
what most gullible most gullible and and
well we have this silly category and
it's silly stupid because
what it because i would i don't like it
today because i think a lot of people
are beautiful
and it was most beautiful but it was
but to me it i was so uncomfortable that
she's getting ready
because it doesn't matter there's no no
it's honestly it really doesn't matter
so for me it was like
i was embarrassed because i thought my
girlfriends were far more beautiful than
me and
i i was really kind of shocked she is
really saying that i'm not kidding you
you've always just been treated you
hated her like
gorgeous and they had all the boyfriends
so it wasn't like i was like um this is
a little weird but it was funny because
i remember you telling me things like i
was
the kid that played the violin or the
violin yeah and then the violin
you'd also go and do cheerleading
lessons or cheerleading
yeah so in junior high i was i played
the violin
i was class historian and this is mind
you i didn't have parents she's no one
telling her so no one told me to do this
and my sister julie and i got perfect
student awards meaning we never missed a
day of school
we were never late we turned in all of
our homework so when we're doing a tardy
because of her
so so i would actually fell in so we
would show up at the event and the party
they threw for us
in junior high and they would have all
these parents sitting there
and grandparents and my sister julie and
i are like perfect students
and didn't have anybody sharing us on so
you know
you just go through those things and you
realize okay you know you have two paths
in life to take and you can make
mistakes but
really you got to keep choosing the
right path because
the wrong path is speaking of the right
the right path
um i feel like that's something you
always do and even at a young age
for example when you told us stories
that these bullies would literally flick
their cigarettes at you and just like
shove you and
to the lockers and throw your books
everywhere when you got picked on so
much you were constantly moving they
used to take
needles and actually stick them in you
as you walked by
it does that i'm telling you it was they
actually
told my mom wasn't around and my
obviously my dad died so i had no
parents
finally the dean of girls at our school
my at the public high school junior high
that i was at
just said to me i'm just going to move
you because
you're getting really no it's awesome
and i would never by the way i never
told on anybody because i would i didn't
i never reciprocated that you were never
doing it i would run
i was actually a faster well that's the
point that's the point i wanted to make
is that you always sort of
came out of the other side stronger even
through all of that
how did you come out the bigger person
in the end knowing
you know you're going through that
you're experiencing the bullying you're
getting picked on yet
you always chose to be the bigger person
at that age how did you
know to make those choices yeah i was
going to say like how did you know
right versus wrong without having any
guidance telling you i think early
parenting
helped a lot i i had actually two
parents when i was young
and and seeing that my my parents always
made us really accountable for actions
we couldn't be jerks we couldn't be
selfish and you couldn't i shared a bed
with my sister until i was 17
and and my other sister so it was three
of us in one room
so you couldn't be like oh this is mine
and this is a so we all i always had to
be
we had to share everything including
underwear i mean like we didn't have
anything that was our own
so growing up like that and then when my
life fell apart when i was 11
i just realized that
i actually am a really good person and i
know these kids are doing really wrong
things to me
but i knew one day that i was going to
get out of here and
i was going to grow up and they were
going to grow up and i was going to move
on from here but i always knew
down in my core who i was and i think
that's really important to understand
that
that's such a good point you just made
that is such a good point it's such a
good point that
you know you're telling our listeners
that but you're also teaching
your daughters to have that and i feel
the same way
and i think it's really special and not
a lot of people have that
that belief that's so strong inside of
them that they're like i know i'm going
to persevere
i know it's hard now but i'm going to
make it out the other end i think that's
really cool
you guys you guys were both bullied a
lot and i know that you sat alone a lot
every lunch because girls
you'd sit down at the table sophia and
they'd walk away and then you'd eat
lunch in the library every day and i've
had to move you guys
like a ton of times i moved you like two
or three schools i moved you twice
just from people bullying you remember
voice shoving locker your face into
lockers
yeah i mean opening up lockers on your
head i remember that one kid
dumped a bucket of paint on my new white
pants i mean
so but then i always used to say to you
girls like
it will get better it will get better
and i always i always knew and i
remember one parent coming to me and
apologizing
to me for their kid bullying you guys
and i looked at her and i'm like listen
i've gone through a lot more than
your little johnny bullying or your
little susie bowling
my kids i've gone through a lot more
hardships than this
so your little kid isn't gonna break us
and i'm not gonna let my kids get broken
by your little brat
that's right mama bear and so i just i'm
said
i'm just gonna keep making you guys
better and smarter and stronger
and this stuff isn't gonna break you
girls and i said just so i'm not gonna
let these idiots
you know what the key was like he was
your involvement
and i think that was really what it was
the consistency and persistence of you
reiterating the fact that be good people
be the bigger person
like we never were the people to
retaliate or even if someone bullied us
sometimes i wish i stuck up for myself
and i think sometimes you even think
about times
you wanted to speak out but you also
thought to yourself you know what
they're obviously going through
something maybe they don't have a great
home life maybe there's someone going
something
internally and you always reminded us
and also i always look at these kids and
i think
what kind of parents raise children that
are so cruel
and i think that if i'm going to yell at
anybody i'm not going to yell at that
kid i'm going to yell at their parents
because their parents are
they're mimicking their product of their
environment exactly yeah so it's always
just to have sympathy for people
even even from really mean people
because you go gosh
what are they dealing with because if
they were happy in their life they
wouldn't and i wasn't totally happy in
my life but i knew that
i was going to get through that time and
i was going to become out a better
person
you you were just strong from the womb
you really were really and i
i want to transition a little bit into
your
career and starting off you are a model
yeah
and we have not very nice like
no i didn't ever want to be a model you
were just
you're so you were so gorgeous you still
are gorgeous but
it was sort of destined for you to
happen and um
but i want to talk about because we have
very similar thoughts on that industry
in your generation and mine it's
somewhat the same still
yeah same people saying it is changing
now it's
changing a lot but body sizes are
changing and i love that they're
bringing
in my more diverse group of uh men and
women
into modeling i love that it's not like
one
one way or that one body size right
seismic and
zero actually now getting called out
for the toxic environment that you guys
were even
raised in no it's it was it was more
than toxic
talk about how you even were approached
into that and what made you continue
being a model and well
first of all i was in college and i was
working a couple jobs to pay for my way
through college
and um so you know i would work in the
morning
and then i'd i would go on interviews
during the day for modeling and then
go to college at night could go to night
school so i was working like two jobs
plus going to college full-time
so i was really exhausted and then
someone came up to me and offered me a
job
like 500 for a couple hours to model
some swimsuits for their catalog and i'm
like oh yeah i'm like oh my god that's
what i weak all week so that's terrific
yes and so that's how i got and got into
modeling and then i started working a
lot and doing commercials
and then um i just dropped out of
college because i was just
my even my college counselor said uh you
can always come back to college but
you're never going to be
what was the commercial that you got
that i did a copper tone commercial
copper tone commercial and i had to
that's what's up
listen listen i was a street girl and i
knew how to roller skate really well
in a bikini and her advisor was like
girl
go you're making me make the money
you're making the money that these kids
are trying to make
go do it yeah you can come back to
college but this is a great opportunity
for you so miss your finals and i'm like
okay it took a chance and it paid off
but yeah it really paid off but while
getting into that modeling world i had
no
idea how thin you have to be
and how you you're afraid to even sip
water it's toxic and they measure you
then they make you get undressed to make
sure
that you don't have remember in our my
generation we didn't have
computers like you guys in photoshop so
they actually had to hand
paint any imperfections on you which was
very so you
really had to be flying so you really
had to be flying the
pressure was immense and i had a more
athletic body yeah so for me
it was really hard to stay super skinny
because i'm naturally like a
like a like a stronger more muscular if
you see my mom flex
and she doesn't even do a push-up yeah
not even a weight not not even a weight
i mean the jeans
on this one so so you can see it at 52
can you imagine what it looked
and i'm not just saying this like the
most perfect body
no but it was it was for like a muscular
type body that was
that's my look but i was doing runway
shows in paris and they want you to be
like uber then uber thing like what did
they say to you
first of all they they said where are
you from i said california like oh
you got to take off your clothes because
we can't have any like straws lose the
tail
lose the tan or they would say to me you
know you've got to be you've got to lose
another five pounds constantly and i'm
like
i'm skin and bones i'm like i ate a
cracker and an apple at night and i'm
like
i'm gonna die i mean it was i mean
imagine in the winter in paris it's so
cold and i was so
i was like 20 19 20. that's a lot of
pressure traveling around the world
by yourself with no money or parents and
no sisters were doing their thing and
they're
like i had nobody checking up on me i
remember i had this russian girlfriend
who
um i said to her i said listen
um i'm going away on this trip or
whatever and nobody knows where i'm at
or what country i think i was going to
morocco for a photo shoot
and i go just here's my name and number
um
and and here's my number of my sisters
in la like if anything happens or you
hear something happens to me
just call them and tell them like lights
out for jennifer or something like
i was just like thinking what what could
i you know i didn't have anybody
checking up on yeah like making sure it
wasn't
those stories that you tell us it just
is so dark and traumatic and
um because i wasn't a super model like i
didn't have
you could have been no but like i wasn't
but i feel like
you saw something bigger for yourself
and i want to go back to that because
you knew deep in your car you're like
modeling is good to pay the money now
but i see a bigger picture and that
bigger picture was your skincare line
yeah
so i want you to talk about how you know
you sort of used what you learned in the
modeling world saw what was missing
right saw how you did things before
proactive and then you
capitalized but not even that she also
did other companies before her skincare
line that
teaches us that you can fail at a couple
things yeah and then
hit that one jackpot right like what you
were doing what was the business i was i
had
started um an athletic wear which was
way before my time
like before now everybody has the
athletic work company i started athletic
wear and i went to
it was so cool i was at the atlantic uh
in atlanta
their trade show for workout wear i was
there
um i so i did that line and then i met
muhammad ali which was really cool i
have a picture of me muhammad ali
so i have to show you that that was
really cool um
and i did an a dress line which i was
starting to manufacture addresses
downtown la and then
i fell into something that was mostly
very passionate to me was skin care
because i had acne i was on accutane
which is a topical
oral medication because i had cystic
acne
so i was always trying different things
to help with my
acne and i lost a lot of jobs in the
modeling world because of my acne
and i couldn't clear it up and
medication wasn't clearing it up and
then so i finally met somebody who had a
skin care clinic
and she educated me on how acne is a
disease it is
you usually and you would inherit it
from a you know you're
just one of your genetic and so she
actually said you know it's a tw
we have to take care of it every 12
hours so in the morning and the evening
so
she set me up with a system of cleansing
treating and healing the skin
and that's how i finally figured it out
with the help of her that actually
topical products really can make a
difference on your skin if you use them
on a regular basis and
you have to be really consistent with
acne as well so i cleared up my skin
i went this is terrific i brought it and
long story short i brought it down to
hsn home shopping network in tampa
florida
they bought like 5 000 units and from
there it was history so then we
went on to 25 years on home shopping
25 years at hsn or at um serious
skincare and
you i mean you're non-stop and you work
day and night and it's funny when you're
telling me the times where you would
start out on hsn and work at like 2 a.m
slots
yeah i'd do like two to four in the
morning and then get like a three hour
break and then go back
on air and then go back i was doing some
like seven eight hours of live
tv a day for four or five days in a row
and then i take a flight home be home
for you girls
and i never liked missing like driving
you to school in the morning picking you
up taking you to all your athletic
product
practices you guys in every sport under
the sun
i made you guys play like basketball she
is wonder woman
soccer i made the run track i made you
guys play
everything how did you get volleyball
though i mean
how did you get you jumped into this
industry where i mean
you had to really learn about it like i
never had an
option like if i failed i sunk
i had to keep swimming even when i met
your dad
it it wasn't like he was his own person
he had made his own money
i had to make my own money right and so
it wasn't like we co-mingled our money
you know sly had his money i had my
money um i paid my own taxes i paid my
own bills he paid his own
and so we came together in a
relationship because i'm not an actress
it was more organic because i didn't
want anything from him
he didn't need anything right from me so
i think that's kind of what
made us work and also kept me working
was
i also didn't want to end up like my mom
with not
knowing how to do anything i wanted to
be i wanted to know how to pay my own
bills i wanted to
have money just in case things fell
apart in a relationship it's really
interesting though because a lot of
people
have habit of just falling to the same
routine or patterns
as their their family and you wanted to
break the cycle and
and that you did and i commend you so
much because you had to sacrifice a lot
i mean every month
you would have to travel to florida you
would have to be
away from your baby sometimes germany it
was a lot it was a lot of work and i
remember sophie and i
you come home and you're just absolutely
exhausted that you
worked and worked and worked and and you
wouldn't say no
and and it's not because you didn't want
to work you retired but you knew you
could do
more and that i think that that is a
hustle that is definitely inherited
i mean that's self-taught well it is
it's self-taught and
i i just wanted to be strong for you
girls i know i i was raising
three um smart independent women that
i wanted to be a good example for you
guys well that you are and as a business
woman
for someone that dropped out of college
has
no knowledge of how to start a business
had no one teaching them
abc this is how you do it what is your
advice for someone out there that
wants to start something of themselves
well first of all you have to make sure
uh that you have hard work in your bones
in your dna
okay because it's hard work and and and
you're going to be working
long hours and and you can't give up
so if you're a quitter and you don't
like to work very hard don't start your
own business work for somebody
else um i always knew i could do it
better
and i knew that i could make it work no
and i would make it work like
there wasn't there was no like there's
no maybe option
and if if this door closed i went
through another one so
for me it was all about real grit real
grit real hard work
and and not and not making it
an excuse and not thinking like i never
because i grew up in a family of seven
and he didn't have anybody
babying me i i didn't need a bunch of
like
oh you have to go to the spa for a week
or you got to go to the gym you know i
i just you know out of a 12-hour day i
would work
15 hours yeah a major opportunity you
weren't sitting around waiting for some
i wasn't hanging around getting a spa
treatment
or going getting my knees yeah i think
the hardest part for a lot of people is
that fear of failure
right they're afraid to even try when i
talk about it with dad
um say if i get rejected time and time
again he goes
failure is the best part of the process
because when you make it
it makes it so much fun how many times
did you
fail get back up on that horse i mean
listen in modeling world i failed a
thousand times i would i would go on
probably like 30 interviews and drive
all over the world and get maybe one job
for a half a day but that one job paid
my rent for that month
and so for me it was like okay keep
going keep going
so i have a question about just even
that alone is
how did you even balance raising us
having a business
um having a stable family life like
that's a lot i mean well
just one job alone i'll tell you what it
takes one of the hardest jobs
you can't be selfish sofia like i knew i
brought you girls into the world you
didn't ask to be brought into the world
so for me it wasn't about me anymore it
was about you guys and it was about my
marriage
and marriages are hard and they can be
you know they have
ups and downs all the time but i knew
that i had to make sure that
um i wasn't having lunch with my friends
every day of the week i wasn't going
like just sitting on eight
eight thousand boards i was actually
home being a parent when you could be
home when i could be home so when i
wasn't working
i was you know if i got off a plane at
five in the morning and i've been
traveling all night to get home i would
get home drive you guys to school then i
would not miss a day of school by the
way she would drive us
every single morning every volleyball
game
she's the room mom i mean you were so
every year
but and i did every year i did a charity
event for your schools to raise money
for the schools
but i just knew that i could i'm a
worker and i
like working and i think it's good for
your mind i don't i i don't look at work
as
work really some people look at work
like oh i'd rather just be
you know i can't wait for the drinking a
beer and like losing my mind like
i think work is so exciting
and i find it stimulating and i and i
love using my brain i love figuring out
problems and
yeah and i like having something to do i
never
i don't like for me i don't like being
lazy
and i know i mean we know you're
constantly moving i mean you guys if you
see
my mom and her element at the house she
is cleaning
moving working organizing cleaning out
closets i mean it's
never it's never sitting down it's never
sitting down
um okay so everyone
that comes across you in their life
basically you're so maternal
to everyone because i look at everybody
like somebody's child and i
i always want to protect them and they
make them feel well
especially especially our ex-boyfriends
my mom
i swear thinks that they are her sons
and she gets very very like don't break
up with them they're so sweet
aren't they they're so nice they're very
well first of all you guys make good
choices
and so i'm proud of that you guys choose
really
nice nice human beings well that's all
from you because you really raised us to
make sure
we knew our worth you you definitely
know you're worth and
and you picked boys or gen nice young
men that were similar to you
oh we'll get into that oh we'll get it
and i love them
and they're very kind i still like they
are good boys they're good boys so we
thought why not give the listeners a
little taste
of of you being maternal towards them
give them some mom advice
because that's one of your favorite
things to do yes constantly showers
with advice yes um i think the first one
the first thing that i came
to my head that i wanted to ask you is
what you wish
you told yourself in your 20s now
knowing that you have two daughters in
their 20s
uh take your time to grow up
like you don't have to hurry um
and enjoy your youth a little bit more
and work is fun and important but also
take a little more time for yourself
okay and and
read a little more educate yourself
constantly educate yourself
that's what i would do more because i
didn't i didn't you didn't do that
enough
no that's good advice i like you and
what about
um what was something that you were the
hardest about
on yourself when you were your 20s like
what was the hardest thing oh
i love being in my 50s because
it is i can exhale yeah i feel like i
can exhale
um in your 20s you you're always in
competition especially
when i was modeling you're always
looking at somebody else and looking at
their best features and wishing you had
those features
yeah now i look at everybody so
differently and i think oh my god they
have great hair but that hair belongs to
them
it's in my hair you appreciate it so
things are opposed to get jealous
of things exactly and you don't look at
yourself like i wish i had that and i
wish i had this on
other people's and and just look at
yourself as being okay
you're okay yeah you have you're lucky
to have what you have and maybe it's not
always perfect
it's so tough it's like being on social
media it's like
so i'm so hard on myself but it's also
nice that you were in the entertainment
field for a bit and you kind of still
are and you you get how we're feeling oh
yeah
i 100 i feel like every little thing on
your body you criticize and you go
oh my god i'm so lucky i have a body i'm
so lucky i have these hands yeah this is
the stomach
i don't care if it has a little pouch
it's still my pouch it's beautiful you
know
all the time i mean we all do this when
we take a photo of ourself
and we go oh my god look at my thighs i
look bad i'm slouching and then you look
at that photo a few years later and you
go
why was i complaining i looked so good
in this picture i mean
it's so silly but i want to talk about
dating advice okay um
typically mom
okay i'll explain when it comes to
dating advice yeah
you and dad give polar opposite
responses
yep true sly obviously thinks like a man
you think
as a little dainty flower that doesn't
want to hurt anyone's feelings and i
love that
i love that about you it's a good
balance it's a good good balance
so we're gonna ask you some dating
advice okay and you can answer it
however you want because this is your
segment
okay okay um so how
did you know when you found the one
aka sly i
knew because i felt that i was home
i felt safe and i felt that he
was my home i know that sounds strange
no that's
i felt secure i felt loved i felt
protected
i felt like we were like just
one and it didn't all the outside noise
didn't matter and i felt like it was
like every time i got
home with him it was it was
it was just perfect secure secure i love
that
this is now in going to new
relationships
how should guys treat you when you're
going into a new relationship and how
should you feel about yourself
well beforehand i mean of course you
should you know
be treated i mean that's a kind of like
you everyone should be treated
well i mean i mean that doesn't but you
know you treat
people how you want to be treated so if
you treat someone poorly then they're
going to treat you poorly
um i mean that's what i hope i mean you
know if you treat someone kind and give
that love to them i always give people
the benefit of the doubt
but then if someone treats me poorly
then i just get rid of them i mean i'm
not gonna waste my time with
i'd rather be alone than be with
somebody that's not nice
i have a question that's sort of aside
from dating
being in your 50s were you ever scared
of reaching that age are you kind of
just happy that you're in your 50s
i'm really happy i'm in my head yeah it
looks like you are i'm really
comfortable i feel like
all that you know noise of like trying
to be perfect
trying to look you know when people see
your dad and i
i think everyone looks at us like oh i
thought they were taller i thought they
were prettier i thought
you know and you always are feeling that
kind of judgy eyes on you
now i don't really care what you think i
really am just like
i'm like this is why i am i'm if you
like me like 100
do you think maybe you're enjoying your
50s now because
you had such a tough childhood and and
adult young adulthood yeah that was just
so true
i didn't really i didn't have a
childhood i think because i was always
working have a job since i was 12 years
old
so now that i'm not working as much
and you girls i would say you're baked
you're raised yeah
you know what the cake is done we are
overcooked you guys are overcooked okay
like you don't need any more advice from
big mama here so i feel like you guys
are doing
really really well and now i can just
sort of like exhale
right and let you girls go and she just
enjoys us to pop out some babies
oh yeah baby i want a baby on each hand
i know and then i want one in this
stroller and i would
honestly i'm so excited for when you've
been grandma i cannot wait to be a
be grandmother i dream of it now i have
just
dogs and cats that i baby like they're
my babies but
um i always tell the slime like oh my
gosh you know that um
mabel kitty is gonna be here when we are
grandparents do you know that
do you know that winnie is gonna be here
for like a certain age
because that's true they're gonna live
at least another 10 years yeah
oh my god that's true they'll be here
when we have kids yeah
they're going to meet i mean hopefully
if we have kids your grandma in training
with the cavapoos right now
yeah yes so of course i went on my
instagram and i posted a photo of you
and i put a little
question box i said we have you on and i
wanted
all the listeners to ask some questions
and we got thousands of responses oh
thank you guys thank you that was yeah
it was crazy and people were losing it
and so
i condensed a few just really good
questions i feel
a lot of people can just relate to and
they go from being a mom to everything
else yeah you can
answer as long or short okay so the
first one
yeah real quick um the first one is
hardest part about raising children
advice for new moms
take help when you can get it like if
you know you need sleep too just like
your baby does and you're a better
parent when you get sleep so if someone
says i can watch your baby for an hour
to say thank you and accept it and go
take a nap because i know that
it's the hardest job i've ever done in
my life was raising kids
and so you need all the help you can get
yeah and and you need your sleep too so
my mom said that she never got
any sleep with me the worst you were up
all night
child she wanted to chuck me out of my
way i actually thought
for a quick second i'm really happy you
did it
um okay the next question is what is
your morning routine specifically your
skincare tips and tricks
morning routine is i i always cleanse my
skin
with my glycolic cleanser and i um
i always cleanse my skin and i always
put an spf on i know that sounds boring
but it is like
great but it's true it was some actually
i've heard that
over doing your skincare routine
sometimes it's
actually harm more than better yeah and
you've always said just keep it simple
yeah and you've saved my whole
volleyball team when i was in high
school
with your skincare products the glycolic
and the dry low you yes my mom was so
funny she would bring
every single player on our teams a
goodie bag of all of her products
yeah the entire time well analyze their
skin so i would look at all their skin
go
okay so your skin's a little dry you
have a little you have some breakouts
you have some pimples i'm going to put
my
dry low on you and by the end of the
season everyone was glowing everyone had
pretty skin
even one of my girlfriends from my team
she wrote and she was like your mom
saved my skin
and i was like that's so nice they
so um mom yes who's your favorite child
that's so mean sophia you know every you
know
we didn't ask the question no there's no
such thing but there isn't such a favor
because all you girls are different
and i love you each individually and
and my life would be over if one of you
wasn't here so it doesn't
you can't i can't okay but she's looking
at me more so i'm assuming
okay but if you ask the question never
never winnie winnie
winnie stallone i knew it we all knew
that
um tips for a happy relationship and
marriage advice
happy relationship um
that's technically marriage advice okay
marriage advice uh
you know marriage is long yeah you know
you're not always gonna be happy and
you're not always so understand that
people also go through different stages
in your life just like kids that go from
their terrible twos
to their you know delightful sevens or
whatever it
you know delightful sevens yes but what
i'm saying is
is that you're going to fight and you're
going to have your you're going to go
different
and also your bodies are changing too so
men go through different changes
women go through menopause so you also
are changing so you got to like
exhale a lot take a break take uh time
out and also
sometimes fighting's good because you
get out a lot of stuff that you've been
holding in
and you let it go and then you're good
again but also
i always recommend to all my friends if
they're having a fight with their
husband
i'm the only one that will say you stay
in the relationship
i mean obviously if they're being
abusive no but like if if
they're just always arguing i go this
time
shall pass right and you guys are gonna
get through this but don't throw away
because you're just going to jump in
another relationship
and by the way there isn't anybody's
relationship
that is perfect and happy all the time
always said to us
never rush things like if you're having
an argument with your significant other
don't rush to decide to divorce them or
break up with them or
don't even rush into marriage before
you're even ready to do it
right really live with those people and
see if you can handle their
their ups and downs their mood swings
their their quirks i mean everybody has
their quirks like yeah i'm very
a-type and my husband is not a-type so
like he's very messy i'm not so can i
live with messi
uh you know things like that so right
that's really important
i think the secret sauce from a kid's
point of view of seeing
your relationship with dad is you guys
are never not laughing
yeah and i think laughter is just the
cure-all for all i think so too i think
also being really silly like i never
take myself seriously and i think
and he'll tease me i'll tease him i love
being
goofy i love being silly i don't want to
be cool i want to have
fun i want to laugh at myself too like
you guys are everyone's got to like you
know everybody's gotta
chill out and you gotta lighten up like
people gotta lighten up
like life is short we gotta have fun and
don't take
if someone says something laugh it off
who cares it doesn't matter you in
and that's the same thing in a marriage
like somebody might say something pretty
cruel or not nice but just like not
laugh it off but like get
over it get over it and you know it
doesn't stick to you unless it's true
right
very true that was nice thank you
this is a good question i probably stole
that from somebody that's okay
that's good no claimers patented that
okay
so this is a little bit more on the
serious side
um i lost my father at an early age just
like you
and now being a wife and mother i can
see the effect it has on many of my
decisions in life
sometimes i feel like i can't move on is
there a way to feel better and accept my
life as it is or will that absence
always be there
well you know you're very blessed to
have
such a beautiful father in your life and
he probably
taught you a lot of really nice things
about
how to be a good parent so you should
look at that as such a blessing
and then also one thing
is is that you can't change what is so
you lost him
and but he is looking down at you and he
is watching you and i know
if he wants you to be happy and what i
always tell
my girls regardless if i'm here or not
in this earth
um no i want you to be happy don't
i you know you can have moments where
you're sad and you miss
your parents but you've got to make
them happy their happiness would be
is because you're happy and i know that
sounds very simplistic
but being um joyful every day
loving your children showing being a
good parent like your dad was a good
parent to you
that's what's making him happy he
doesn't want to see you sad he doesn't
want to see you depressed he doesn't
want to see you like
every day you know just change it up and
say
how would my dad what would my dad what
advice would he probably give me is
i want you to live your life and smile
more
laugh more love your kids more give them
hugs
tell them how great they are that's one
thing i always told you guys i digress
is i always told you how smart you are
how kind you are how beautiful you are
inside and out
and constantly giving you and telling
you how much i love you
every single day yeah i would rub your
faces every night and say what good kid
you are
and how pretty you are and how sweet you
are long term i don't think you realize
what that does to a kid's brain
it does and it costs nothing it costs it
changed
everything for us it just really meant
the world
i always say that we remember not the
times that
she threw us a big birthday party or the
or the
vacations it was genuinely the
time she drove us to school and picked
us up the time she would sit by her bed
and hold her
hand on our forehead until we would fall
asleep just to have that
pressure and that warmth there to show
that she was around
and just those tiny moments were way
more significant when i'm older and i'm
going to do with my kids
than these lavish things that they
assume
is what you know wins i think i i
remember i think it might have
been scarlett um i woke up at like three
in the morning
and she woke up at the same time and we
met in the kitchen we had a bowl of
cereal
together and to her that was like one of
the greatest memories
it is such a simple memory but those are
the things
that are important in life and kids
remember let's remember it's not you
know
spending every second with your children
but it's also just spending quality time
and
letting them know how proud you are of
them
how smart they are how good they are
constantly reinforcing that in your
kid every single day makes a difference
how did we get so
i know you guys i'm lucky i got listen
this is all i wanted to be in life as a
mom so
when i was i was a little girl my
sisters and i would lay in bed at night
and say
we just want to be mom oh you were built
you were built for this job i was built
what type of guys do you think sophia
and sistine would end up marrying
okay i think
both of you are gonna marry very
smart entrepreneurial type
men okay um but what's a specific body
thing i think
for her okay you're gonna marry
definitely a tall
um very kind of more nerdy type
of guy oh girl i think sistine
is gonna marry a little bit more
muscular
um someone who is likes to joke because
you
are super funny and so i love them and
you like to joke around
and you have a very dry sense of humor
so i think you're gonna have someone
who's very witty
and very funny and you're gonna marry
someone very smart
and clever both are going to be
hard-working
intelligent men and both will give you
lots of babies
approval if she doesn't like them we're
not getting them oh yeah
so if you guys want to go out with us
you have to go through her first oh my
goodness
okay so we're going to wrap up the show
i think this is a good
question to end with someone asked you
what is the most important lesson in
life
which is such a pride big question but
answer is the most important question i
don't know um
just one happiness
i mean we all want to be happy and
healthy i guess
i know so it's very simple but it is
yeah what life is all about yeah like
make decisions that make you happy no
matter if you live
you know 30 years or 100 years you kind
of want to go through life being happy
whatever which way that gets you i love
that
mama thank you so much for coming on the
show today she's our mama
we're all giving hugs right now mom you
did a really good job thank you
um i hope we did you proud today you
guys are awesome i know i'm so proud of
you oh thank you i know once this
episode
comes out they're going to request you
every single time and maybe if you guys
want to give us some tips of what you
want to see from her next time for a
part two
might be fun maybe different questions
but honestly like i'm
i this exceeded my expectations
any final thoughts i don't know just
keep going strong girls you're doing
everything right thank you guys for
joining us on this week's episode with
our
beautiful lovely mother jennifer
stallone
stay tuned for next week's episode and
hopefully we'll have her back on
see y'all tuesday bye from all of us
here at the show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week
you